mic so much of this movie is about how
people look for kind of crazy ways in
which to validate their work in their
lives and I just have to say what's your
run Tomatoes score right now oh my god
yeah I actually do know my rounds and
and what is it
it's 83% could be worse yeah like the
movie came out yesterday and so like
you're like hey you know box-office
updates and I'm like okay and
everything's good but it's like one of
the emails was like and your audience
score on Rotten Tomatoes is like really
high and I was like is this another
thing I need to like look at like yeah
great that was something else so like
check the wins of like are we up forcing
to be that person but it's like it's
like being in a casino like even if
you're up you're down like you're up but
like get out of the casino step away
from the casino you're gonna lose
eventually get away from the casino Mike
I wanna ask you about a couple things
that are going on this movie but I'm
gonna start by having a conversation
about your dad Mel and at what point was
he the inspiration for what you were
writing and at what point did everything
around you that you were noticing about
ways in which people you worked with and
went to school with were measuring
themselves against one another do those
two things happen simultaneously I did
want to see the other well considering
he's he's my dad at what point was he
the inspiration for a father-son movie
as pre you I couldn't like pretty far
back ago I guess but um my dad is a
writer I you know I think I when I was
young I saw that my dad had this real
had this relationship that was with like
the world or you know some you know it's
like it's like you have your
relationship with your wife and your
kids and friends or whatever but there
was this other relationship that he had
with like how he felt like he was I
don't know yeah I like where he was with
the world
and I realized that was like a real
relationship for him you know and I
think people in this business can
understand that you know it's like it's
a delusional relationship but it is
something that you like feel is
something you take some kind of stock in
or you're like conscious of and so yeah
that was something that I thought you
know it isn't explored a lot in movies
you know you have a lot of romance or
whatever like family stuff but this
thing of like you know how where's my
status where do I stand and you know it
does the world love me and you know can
I love the world even if the world
doesn't love me and those ideas yeah so
often when you read Mike script how do
you connect to it how does it land in
your mind about something that you want
to do and that you see away into plain
Troy I mean well I mean for you know
initially into wanting to do it I mean
you know he's an incredible writer and
director and then Ben and the script was
incredible so I mean that was you know
main kind of draw and then I mean I kind
of I mean honestly like relate to it in
a lot of ways like even though you know
Brad is supposed to be you know you know
you know 40s or what-have-you like I you
know I have those situations constantly
in my brain well I'm just kind of
comparing myself to you know this person
or you know another you know actor
that's you know my age or something
because there's a lot of you know
there's a lot of like you know good ones
now or at least ones that I think that
are good and so yeah I could definitely
relate to that and then I and and then
what drew me to the character that he
wrote is really the kind of maturity and
the thoughtfulness that he had which was
like you know really different as
compared to like a lot of like you know
teenagers I don't know that Troy has
this [ __ ] together more than his dad
it's basically which I thought was you
know really interesting and interesting
you know difference between them Jenna
Melanie is in a marriage that I think a
lot of men and women wish they were in
and even when they're in it they don't
recognize it for what it is when you
read what Mike is written and what you
think it has to say about a marriage
way in which a marriage can work the way
in which people don't really see what is
right in front of them how did you
respond to it what are the conversations
you had with Mike about where you saw
this marriage going and how it how it is
working well when I read the script the
thing that I really loved about it is
that a lot of times the wife is a pretty
thankless role and an underdeveloped
person whose job it is to just sort of
like unconditionally lovingly accept
everything that her husband is doing and
while the character of Melanie is really
accepting it's coming from a different
place it's she's a full character she's
feisty and she fights for social social
justice causes and she the thing that I
related to is that it kind of mirrors my
own marriage except that I'm Brad my
husband is Melanie my husband is very
self-confident and self-contained and is
an independent person and as I spin out
in my multiple anxiety attacks and
neurotic social anxieties he just loves
me and is separate from me and is able
to be separate from me and allow me to
be me and he can be him and I think it's
rare in a marriage I've not ever had a
relationship or anything like that
before so it was exciting for me to see
it on the page and then see it in a
movie
have you guys very healthy have you and
your husband watched the movie together
yeah yeah and what was that like um he
loves the movie oh my gosh he well I
mean we loved Mike we loved his work and
he loved it and he will tell you that he
is Melanie in that I am he knows we both
know it that's why it works
that's all good Mike at what point do
you decide that this is a script that
you want to direct and what triggered
that decision with this project mmm I
guess for me it's like when it's more
stressful to not direct it than to
direct it is when I do it like it's like
sometimes like there's certain ones here
I'm like I know I'm we on this set be
like that's how you're covering it
really
okay I'll just be over here having a
panic attack so like with this one I
felt like the tone was very like
specific and yeah like so I was like I
just felt like it would be more like
trying to get a direct to manipulate a
director into like so rather to
manipulate some other director just
manipulate yourself yeah yeah Mike
Austin Jenna thank you for making the
movie thank you guys for coming around
making